es sollte ihr paradies werden eine villa
im bulgarischen dorf mobil ist vor acht
jahren kam das ehepaar aus deutschland
hierher kaufte für eine bescheidene
summe ein großes anwesen und wollte hier
alt werden
doch dann kam alles ganz anders zur
eigenen sicherheit für libysches volk
oder betrüger abzocker die herumfahren
die ausspionieren weil sie nicht auch
noch weiter wissen wie zu stehen
sonst könnten nicht überleben die sind
aber besser betreuen
das haus gleicht einem
hochsicherheitstrakt die
überwachungskameras laufen tag und nacht
es geht traut kaum noch jemandem mit in
seinem dorf jahr kamera 1
dieses grundstück sowie die kamera 2
bringt unser orangerie der aufwand ihr
eigenheim zu schützen ist riesig und
kostet geld das die es nicht haben denn
ihr leben im einst so günstigen
bulgarien wird immer teurer
ihre ursprüngliche kalkulation reicht
nicht nicht in bulgarien und erst recht
nicht mehr daheim in deutschland habe
ich kein auto
deutschland ist keine alternative
aber in bulgarien will ralf es nicht
bleiben
seine nachbarn sind weggezogen viele
davon deutsche und briten die wie er in
großen anwesen in mobil ist er alt
werden wollten
denn auch zu bulgaren haben die es kaum
kontakt tanja die verkäuferin des
dorfladens kennt geht zwar seit vielen
jahren aber sie ist distanziert denn
viel mehr als brot wasser oder danke
kann recht nicht sagen was soll man da
reden
das interesse dafür und ich habe auch
nicht die zeit gehabt als anfang dafür
zu lernen und dafür hat mir das viel zu
viel arbeit am haus auch nach acht
jahren im og liste leben die deutschen
im dorf isoliert enttäuschte hoffnungen
dabei hatten die nähe zum schwarzen meer
das tolle klima hier in der region um
varna und die günstigen preise die es
einst für bulgarien begeistert sowie
rund 25000 andere deutsche und britische
rentner die hierher ausgewandert sind
jedes jahr werden es mehr doch wie
folgenschwer diese entscheidung sein
kann ist vielen nicht klar
der österreicher manfred stiefel kennt
das problem er leitet die firma lebens
residenz in varna und berät deutsche
rentner die nach bulgarien wollen auch
in diesem appartmenthaus der wohnungen
vermittelt zurzeit ist hier ausgebucht
doch er warnt davor voreilig im alter
ins ausland zu ziehen
sie werden auch getrieben von der
vorstellung dass sie sich mit den
vermutlich auf einem möglichen
finanziellen mitteln hier ein goldenes
leben eher kaufen können und enden dann
sehr oft in einer in einer spirale wo
das noch viel viel schlimmer für sie
nicht wir haben wir haben einfach dann
sehr oft leute die die nicht mehr
zurückkehren weil sie in deutschland
alles veräußert haben doch nicht alle
sind unzufrieden
die 76-jährige an alex aus stuttgart
wollte mit ihrem mann auf dem motorboot
lara rund um europa schippern
seit ihr mann vor zwei jahren unterwegs
an einer schweren krankheit starb lebt
sie allein im yachthafen von varna ihr
boot und bulgarien sind zur neuen heimat
geworden
sie will hier bleiben die leute haben
noch zeit zum reden zum beispiel beim
kartenkauf man so stehen bleiben anregen
es gibt es das schon dass nicht nur das
muss also jetzt muss alles schnell
schnell schnell schnell
das macht es sein lebenswerk und dann
ist die landschaft schön wäre natürlich
für bernadette und reschke dagegen sind
das meer und die strände heute kein
trost
doch in die alte heimat deutschland
führt für die es wohl kein weg mehr
zurück